hello and welcome back to Playstation
grenade it's been a while but I think
it's time to go back and see what Jeff
had is up to if you've watched the last
two episodes we've gone through
developmental that we found ourselves in
the title fight against the mold you're
here on NXT what there is a little trick
to this this is a No Disqualification
match which is also a triple threat and
we don't know who the third person is
yet so let's see let's just sit back and
enjoy Jeff jumping around like the good
old days in the 90s
[Applause]
so nice time for Samoa jaw but if you've
not been watching recently this
introduction might confuse you basically
for another video we were looking at
different entrances of prep wrestlers
and this is what we have the Samoa Joe
wearing Daniel Bryan gear I'll put a
link if you want to look at some of the
weird entrances that we've we've made in
the past including The Bella Twins mixed
with Undertaker and Kane it's definitely
worth your time anyway back to what
we're doing today triple threat match
Jeff Hardy versus Samoa Joe for that
title but there's still another person
we don't know who it is yet let's see
who the third person is hang on hang on
is he back haha fantastic one of the
reasons why I love this invasion Lord is
because you get moments like this
our biddies here his debut in NXT will
be up against Jeff and some old your for
the NXT title and let's get one thing
straight
this episode will only end once we win a
title this is the third episode we've
been climbing the ladder this one has to
be it so now we'll take on these two
let's try this
so mojo is the favorite he's been
wrecking me for weeks so let's see how
we go
[Applause]
that's not the stuff I wanted yes a mojo
is going to be a difficult long day at
the office but if we stay away we keep
our distance and then I'm gonna jumpsuit
little Santa fits and what a great
opportunity this is for these guys to
build momentum
we got a triple threat match but about
triple threat oh and remind some already
okay this is this is terrible it's okay
this American it's not a sprint keep our
distance and just attack from behind
every so often Oh lovely try and get our
biddies head to bounce off the ring post
move referee Oh delicious that's what
I'm talking it's cooling me again as we
speak
so just just having to lay down outside
while these two Samoa jaw is absolutely
wrecking everyone I can't see the gold
being taken away from his waist its
considerable waste that is Oh Jeff
sandwich
is a Gary here and fast
he's on the defensive now he's starting
to feel the pressure
Van Dam's regretting coming back to WWE
oh man this is gonna be painful for him
whoa he's out he's out cold
come on jefra stagger over we've seen
some unlikely Ally RV knees giving us
some space
thanks RVD make it up to you later here
tonight right here we go perfect oh oh
damn it the more ring away for a lay
down he might want to miss things
Happiny could win this he really could
is it on for the five-star surprise
versus the frontier [ __ ] come on
gonna break it up break it up
or palpable just in the nick of time
quite impressed with that one Brian
let's get some reversals on the girl we
haven't reversed anything yet in this
match this taking a good moderate
offense here going to need to start
playing a little better defense on my
way right this is oh you're not going to
kill me there
oh is it oh that's closer than I
expected I'll be knees on the outside
which means if someone can pull off a
finisher around now you might have a pin
on the girl cut count let's go
it's over go positive just to tell you
yes to tell how much more how much more
are you willing to pay to win this match
this is unreal we worry about
juries for sure that he got it is this
it is this the end one - no it's still
going this much is a doozy as they say
oh no I reverse something it's the first
we reverse something and he's taking so
long
[Applause]
ah to love them
no idea which girls smell the intensity
of this been in knots a grappler that
will only make sense to people who watch
the episode would he's studying a
message to the entire WWE locker one
just roll over it's not it's still going
side effects
more jobs not getting up so come on
please retic count quicker everyone do
great he's still going for this much
scene I just want that belt it's all
wrong
Swanton bomb for the win this has got to
be it
come on champion NXT champion three
three this this is it
sadly I'm gonna lose every day on his
debut he's gonna it's gonna win the NXT
title and I've been fighting for months
for this eyes up it's still going way
too much on a championship ridiculously
high quality much
each every one of them
it's got a chancer you gonna go kick him
out otherwise I could have worn it then
he went down hard
oh well stand up Joe
stand up John's got some flips to do
return of team extreme we ha ha ha it's
like two drinks up I never seen you look
is a nerve lose you doing today you know
so and amazing I'm sorry again
[Applause]
would you get this can you
will to succeed some mojo is in person
oh no reversal this is this is it get up
get up get up get up get up
one two one three
that wasn't three that was - that was -
the ref said - scandal absolute scandal
I don't add a Paquette about these
highlights and I should have been
through but I don't care about these
highlights cookware we need to rewind
we need to look at this right this is a
two-count and then he changes really one
to change that's a to cap that is a
two-count what got the rap one two and
I'll even
impressive performance I don't know what
to do every time we get a title shot we
get that's us get something like that
that was a two-count that was never a
three me ladies and gentlemen
thank you for joining the system
okay I've slept on it I've slept on it I
don't mind about losing that much
because I've got another idea so bear
with me here I'm gonna get that title
but there's a problem there's an issue
there's an elephant in the room as they
say so Jeff over to you felt very well
I've been going it alone for a long time
now but that has to change
and I've got someone in mind who I'd
like to say a few words to hopefully our
v/d will hear me out I'm sure you've
already figured out what I'm going to do
[Applause]
this quite crowds a bit flat isn't it
come on Roberto
I'm fond um in the ring you old fart he
really loves that Mike something tells
me he's all business tonight let's see
what he has to say yeah this should be
good
[Applause]
I'm kind of surprised to hear from you
but I've got to say that I am interested
in hearing you out so let's get on with
it
what have you got to say come on Jeff
spit the words you and I dog have a lot
in common
one thing we both want is success we
both want that now I'm not saying you
can't do it on your own so don't take
this the wrong way but I think together
we can do this and become the greatest
dog team in history I should get here by
the crowd
basically RBD agrees good luck
so team Xtreme no team team Hancock can
call ya team Hancock so from this day
forward
Jeff Hardy and Rob Van Dam will be known
as team hardcore so we're switching
we're going to go for the tag team
titles instead and I think we've got it
we can do this we have the skill we
definitely have the talent and we have
the drive team hard core our dear view
matches the tag team we're going up
against the champions it's not for the
title which is a shame come interrupt
this intro because it is a terribly
boring watching two men what to a ring
in underpants no no
that's more like it
[Music]
[Music]
this tag match really does have a big
fight feel and everyone in attendance
feels it too I feel it or that could be
the tacos I had for lunch
oh man I'm really looking forward to
this tag-team match
[Music]
our tag team debut so it's all about in
this match is reversals and double teams
let's see what we offer maybe not right
let's try that again
reverse IO and get him in the corner and
we'll see what gh and RVD can do
together this looks promising Eric
around a powerbomb is it something like
that haha
now that is double-team at his best
excellent working it's amazing how
aggressive this magical let's keep on
the top ropes
since this contest was this crap dumps
and ended a better do the crab dance for
that edge coming through here oops okay
can go wrong but you've just got to keep
trying RVD if at first you don't succeed
try try and try again let's have some
flips
things are looking fun 15 hardcore I'm
so impressed AHA ribs for the bright
star fives down get a dime staff as a
prepares tag-team division is ours one
two okay tactically we need to worry
about the second person now I'll learn
Jeff what we got a dropkick
just it's a massive kick in the head
I like your style come on stand up
bearded molded guy have a side effect
it's in the face and let's finish this
now the twist of fate I absolutely adore
this move on Tom bond can I get away
with it can I get away oh no
punched in the book holes punched in the
book cheek ow
okay don't use their corner live and
learn young man live and learn you get
down right that's why I'm after Rolling
Thunder
[Applause]
he's down
I mean iccup in can we Nick a pin is
this our debut wins one two no but we
caught snow nut Mary's up something am i
right I don't know these moves just get
on the top rope and give us some
five-star five-star five-star five-star
five-star frog splash
[Applause]
getting up from that well now give that
guy a knock in the ribs
this must be it the one two three four
debut victory it shoulders you down on
us
boys I don't know what three years yeah
team hardcore Opta winning where is this
is it you know I think we're gonna get
this title pretty quick
[Applause]
rub em damn you want to talk about
tag-team war you know definitely let
this just back this is energy you know
so we fought these guys a few times now
so let's just cut this down into just
random things that we do such as the
spinning upside grappler so effect by
Scott Carson
there's the finisher this might be over
and you can also have the greatest move
most underrated move there is it again
[Applause]
let's go up top downtown run down you
just stay out the match it's completely
down to Jeff this must be a switch a
good move such a good move a safe in
Toronto great oh no guys good so yeah
we've been beating these guys all month
soon we will get a title shot I am so
sure of that in fact these guys are
starting to fall out the guy outside is
he even across Scott Dawson is either
the guy with the red Underpants he's not
happy
[Applause]
without
Oh gents this division already this is
going to be the easiest title ring ever
there's a bit tag-team matchup here
tonight again it's not for the title
this time around but we're still we're
still going to have a door it's still
gonna absolutely beat them and hopefully
we will get a title shop so maybe it
takeover maybe we have to wait for Mom
my cinema will keep beating them we must
get a title shot running top finisher
writes down over mousse now that's a
finishing move this thing might be all
oops that wasn't intended I was trying
to hit Scott Larson
I like that load something new to do was
trying to change it in Wistar fate such
a moment new stuff
let's just keep smashing them with
finishes until they give us a title shot
yes we can do this all day gentlemen
[Applause]
this must be it one two three yes
I'm hoping now we get a title shot this
has been six matches in a row either
singles or tag-team we had a two-on-one
in there as well
their team is broken it's beaten team
hardcore is here for the titles can we
get our first ever title we will see all
that work has paid off because we're
here without the tag team championship
match let's just serve at the moment
breathe it in breathe it in introducing
the Challenger and a combined weight of
before
and 36 pounds Chevy and the
unpredictable teen hardcore and
introducing the champion at a combined
weight of four hundred and forty nine
pounds there are the NXT Tag Team
Champions God Dawson
in a few seconds the wait is over and we
will finally get this match underway
look at the gold ooh
chills right some of our strong start
gents if we can start on the front foot
we will have this in the bag early doors
so let's do this in a bit before we even
get on the things we're gonna need to
show some guts and heart if they hope to
leave here with the gold always
interested to see super stars that's
Jeff Hardy from the top rope come on
keep it hardcore right rethink competing
run away this is a tile match we need to
win this this isn't about looking good
this is about survival
no please Jeff come on Jeff get up get
up I'm through my worm a quarter of a
second away from losing our title
fighting stay alive we need to get Rob
Van Dam in because we are struggling
this looks like a rainbow this is not
one to plan at all yes tikka time when
he gets proud you'll get in simple as
that
look at the emotion then just when he
comes over get it I'll stop by because
it's your nachos joke for it true it's
the final and carry nick frickin
backbreaking thing
we need to reverse for me to reverse
them tonight thank you so much right Rob
get in then it gets the tear get my
kicking fierce and so you it knows you
here right a biddies got this
he's the only one still with full health
and stamina so look at Jeff he's gonna
fall over any second yes wild wasn't
serious trouble yes Rob punched out if
she's going so well but a Rolling
Thunder you know where he's going up the
Rolling Thunder he's going upstairs from
the top Rob Robert ba-bam bam with the
finisher he's not an opinion yet he
wants more action the jacket why am i
bringing Jeff back in Jeff is the most
packet out of the wall come on Jeff
don't mess about I don't like the look
in his eye here [ __ ] finish the match
finish the match such a good move it's
wanton bond from the top take that guy I
jump down right we'll try and sneak a
pin I don't think this is gonna work
one too close but no cigar okay right
thank you rob thank you rob and ask at
this title match gets got me so stressed
scorp stressed suggest to someone I'll
lay down Rob you just keep beating them
up because Jeff can barely function
it's like that much again sting do you
ever watch it
in this contest he's too busy bragging
it without finishes
let's give him a twist of fate perfect
just getting to get rid of that Scot guy
got up quits kick him in the head like
still open still defense the elephant
come on this is our only chance this is
it this is my first ever championship
first ever championship come on everyone
we've hit it at long last
oh my word it took three episodes to get
here but we have finally won a title
thank you Rob Van Dam thank you whoever
whoever brought that guy in for an
invasion lord thank you so much I this
is down to you NXT champions we did it
wow what a journey get on that rocks Jen
Jen Sanna just enjoy the moment well
there's a team hardcore so what do we do
next well I'm gonna replay this we need
to just watch them celebrate for the
first time just look how happy Jeff is
there are so cute right what's gonna
happen next
shall we try and defend our annex
details shall we go for the the main
title NXT championship
shall we go against the new day our
Cesaro and Cheer --mess and see which
tag team is the best in the world it's
up to you let us know what you'd like to
do in episode 4 and we'll do it sorry
it's taken me so long to get this one
done things have been very busy but if
you keep watching I'll keep making these
by the way if you new around these parts
please have a look at some of our other
content and maybe even subscribe next
few times basically soon Tag Team
Champion